deserted streets around the Soleil
Pagoda people in Yangon defiantly
showing their support for the silent
strike as officers and shops remain
closed despite warnings from the
military scenes like this were repeated
across Myanmar on Wednesday
but in Bangkok where they were free to
speak out they did
hundreds of Myanmar citizens
demonstrated outside their Embassy
denouncing the coup and the general
behind it
many held up pictures of aung San tsuchi
the last elected leader now facing a
lifetime in jail we not
everyone to show that all the world that
hey look at the Burma and come and help
the Burma stay with the Burma stand with
the Burma yeah
we are here to protest Myanmar is really
bad right now Minong lie destroyed the
country and he kills a lot of people
at this stage senior General Minong Lai
shows no sign of backing down the
military has used the full force of its
Arsenal in the past 12 months Heavy
Artillery armor and increasingly
airstrikes but resistance is strong
across the country many clearly still
refuse to accept military rule what we
have is the strong commitment of the
people and the people are very resilient
but also ready to fight against the
military by all means possible that is
what military don't have that the United
Nations a concession that the
international response to the crisis has
been disjointed and weak that is what is
missing when it comes to Myanmar that
kind of strategic coordinated approach
by a coalition of countries much like we
saw with respect to the Ukraine crisis
we've yet to see with respect to the
Myanmar crisis the tactics of myanmar's
military when they forced more than
million ethnic rohingya to flee and now
being repeated across the country yet
many neighboring Nations still refuse to
condemn the generals nor off a sanctuary
or Aid to those suffering inside
on the border with Thailand boats Ferry
supplies across the Myanmar the World
Bank estimates the economy has shrunk by
15 since the coup food shortages are
widespread
while some trade is getting across the
border like inside Myanmar seems to be
getting increasingly difficult under
military rule 22 million people living
below the poverty line Millions more
displaced by fighting and basic services
like education and Healthcare
essentially gone
Tony Chang Al Jazeera on the time Yamaha
border